thank you for the microphone
thank you instructors
[Music]
um
these all downloads remember to raise a
hand if you miss your feet so it changes
[Music]
please speak directly into the
microphones
[Music]
the channel request that you do not
stand on the speaking so that you can
get as close to the microphone as
possible
then we'll switch off the microphone
when you have finished
[Music]
thank you
thank you so anyway
um
[Music]
thank you
declarations
[Music]
thank you
three minutes of the last minute
was the run for Monday the 30th of
January 2023 are you happy that they are
looking
so
thank you
for those info
and again
and the extension
emotions being carried
thank you I see Falls for chairs and
their excellence
firstly by saying thank you to the man
of trust and our team here at the office
for having a speeding physics problems
and also to thank those people that are
attended by Civic event on Thursday yeah
not only for the people that attended
but for those who participated in the
event and for all those that work behind
the scenes and it's made a very
successful event the feedback has been
working here
moving on we have three upcoming events
for birthday month on Friday the 17th of
March but if it's not been available and
these can be encourages through the fire
the office well
[Music]
performance
thank you
so
yeah with the current term of office
going to be closing in the elections
moving I want to take it up into the
bank all members from across the gamer
we also there's your community and
Northview Township Council as a home in
particular is
your contributions and dedication to the
council and to those who aren't even
reactive I wish you all look but as you
imagine I would solve a bit more than
others
[Music]
it's quite amazing to consider how
different both the chemicals and more
consider shift looked back then since
everybody did what they do now it's
almost entirely different world
television has been redefined the way we
operate and for a short period it
transformed our role and function almost
entirely of your lord remembering prayer
with the way he canceled September
through the pandemic and lockdown
whether that was keeping attention
services like any collections running
delivery prescriptions supporting Goods
need to access Government funding
keeping in regular contact with our most
vulnerable weapons and supporting the
vaccinating level with over 50 000 jobs
[Music]
is now getting well underway
if that says across the district have
seen significant transformation we now
have four rather than three District
campuses with killing Arch activities
added to our portfolio following the 1.9
million pound Redevelopment emissions
and the investment in library paying off
memberships at their highest level 80 by
the fact that we have Frozen our beans
despite the impacted explosion to the
Quality District to keep healthy on kids
[Music]
wherever it arises and while I know it's
incredibly contentious and a difficult
issue for example to agree the adoption
of a local Farm is already bearing
fruits in preventing the speculative
inappropriate development we've been
played with the past decade or more
[Music]
as well as a range of other important
projects across the business
we prioritize ensuring that residency
real tangible Improvement to their
community and that's exactly what we're
going through our efforts on perhaps our
most important achievement there is
having been there to support our most
vulnerable not only declaratively but in
many other ways well
when putting ways with vicious illegal
war in the Ukraine we were quick to Mark
our support for the Ukrainian population
and we supported many of our residents
who have been extremely generous and
throwing open their doors to welcome
clearing Museum
[Music]
The Wider impact of the war and turned
lending bills in place when the
resultant
has affected every single person in the
district and I'm extremely proud of the
way we've come together and work
together at the council from across the
political Factory and with our fantastic
offices we ensure we are offering as
much support as we possibly can to our
residents and visitors if they're in the
very clear message to people we will
always be here
[Music]
thank you
I'd like to invite portfolio
[Music]
the increasingly difficult Marketplace
for recruitment
we also know that good workforce
planning will help ensure that Workforce
requirements are aligned to the
achievements of attractive objectives
whilst having one hand in the Horizon
without playing for the plan to open the
new Founders ahead
these good organizations
as councils as a council we have a
significant role to play in community
leadership and improving the outcome and
life chances of those in our communities
[Music]
I think to leaders and as a local
Council this is exactly what we should
be doing leading by example and the hope
that we might improve just quickly to
explore the disability investing in our
people and investing in our communities
I would also like to give thanks for the
officers that have worked on this and
the leadership that uh that lead himself
has provided in developing this
trafficker I think it's an article where
Exxon got
[Music]
um
so thank you for that please you'll be
happy to continue with the presentation
thank you
thank you thank you
and thank you Council for this afternoon
today uh showcase
uh
[Music]
this is a National Review
the recent survey now
he began the next slide please
so in a recent survey here
knowing after 10 times
[Music]
and increasingly
where agencies
and that adds more pressure to our
services department
sort of external recruitment issues are
one thing
[Music]
reports it
we have a whole teams that are almost
the same age
science represent a great picture of
everybody's attention
this professional residue for brain
throwing and skill blocks all these new
organization at once
so understanding the external challenges
our own Workforce profile and the
importance of right across the timing
man
[Music]
so we can enjoy the fruits and use the
phone
[Music]
so what's the fun part of line for
example Investments on an investment
[Music]
this is not about huge investment in
cash experience this is about using our
existing Resource
One so if I see more of our time
foreign
[Music]
so
it's an investment in Layton for a
blossoming time and the identification
of potential future employees
and I think it's our applicability that
we can and shield through our own family
this is far from an easy way and we know
that
our goal isn't essentially
this is about culture this is about
people who are the sense of loyalty
employees and what they do and what they
are achieving for what they might wish
for the children
this is a visible investment in our
existence
potential students on the organization
so this is about succession time
which is about Amazon
[Music]
foreign
um
finally when we launched this we're not
fairly important Right audience
on screen is an example
the key to this would be the work page
ants
[Music]
it will be a place where the chair pays
that we are reflectively many businesses
each business
[Music]
in my opinion the idea of organizations
perhaps most importantly
we were trying to get across the message
[Music]
it is
I'm going to show you one example today
[Music]
thank you
for us
to work
without
growing understand the real idea of
potential
this is a short video that's been
produced by our constitute of coloring
discussion on Sunday we played this
video please Joe
thank you
the talent pipeline is really all about
taking a longer term approach to
recruitment rather than the traditional
one
it's an approach that recognizes that
the goal it's not simply about filling
vacancies the goal is part of the right
people in the right posts and that's not
a quick win
it's about investing time and energy
into people up front getting them ready
for positions before they become vacant
we're starting early with high quality
work experience and engagement with
schools and colleges we're creating
volunteering opportunities that are
non-committal and flexible we're
establishing apprenticeships as a key
Pathway to employment and progression
with an emphasis on growing our own
people and we position our Council as a
go-to Organization for high quality
graduate placement with a graduate
scheme that will attract people Beyond
University
pipeline we're building on an already
successful one-team culture here at Norm
feaster
if I were to put it simply
we're creating an environment where
people can be and want to be successful
I'm living Vickers I'm the current comms
management Northeast Abshire District
Council and I started here seven years
ago as a digital media officer and prior
to that I worked at bolsover District
Council for two years as a temporary
technical officer okay so I started off
as I say as a financial services
apprentice and I did my aat level two
level three and level four which made me
a qualified aat technician and now I've
just started sit first so that's the
chartered Institute of Public Finance
accountancy it's become a chartered
accountant
so when I started at the Northeast
casual lifeguard and which enabled me I
had to do my lifeguard qualification
as I wanted to develop up through the
ranks I developed a swim teaching and
then went on to my business management
so that helped me become head attendant
and then obviously helped me to become a
Jewish officer I'm Madeline Fern and I
started last year as an apprentice
assistant accountant I was working at
level two and now I'm level three
so when I first started ADC I never
thought that I'd ever become where I am
now I just thought I'd be a vehicle
mechanic and that was it but the
opportunities and the courses and the
progression that you can go through and
the training provided is
basically whatever you want that I love
your job and so the main benefits of
working here for me personally
um having a young family at home
um means the flexibility of working it's
just brilliant be that the hours where I
could come in a little bit later if you
need to drop my daughter off at school
um or working from home because it you
know we tend to do a hybrid work in here
that means I get to be at home see my
family a little bit more than I would if
it was full five days in the office and
that that person there for me is is
brilliant
um and then in the job role itself the
fact that I feel like we're empowering
the residents and our businesses and I'm
giving back to the community I guess
through the world but it's the fact that
it's a council that doesn't care about
its residence and we are really
passionate about our communities it's
just really really
um I guess empowering you know how you
spend I don't know you work at least
eight hours a day with them you spend
more time we work colleagues than you do
with my wife at home so you get that
friendly ship and you and because you're
always you're never on your own in
pleasure you're always with someone so
you bounce off them all time and it just
creates that just nice friendly
environment obviously always working
with customers and stuff like that so it
isn't it is nice so I would say if
you're looking for an apprenticeship
it's definitely a brilliant place to
come to work and they provide you with
the support that you need and they
always say when you get a job at the
council you've got a job for life and I
do actually think that that is very true
um it's very supportive place to work
really nice people and I could see
myself working here for a really long
time
when you get learning opportunities in
your day-to-day work life and answering
the phones and work in an office that's
a lot of learning and you also get your
classroom in college and but I was also
recently given the chance to do a first
aid course which I think is a really
valuable skill for life in January
Leduc staff are fantastic
um anything
any queries any problems struggling with
work there's always somewhere to help
yeah
um regards training pay for all the
training plus you get paid as well
which is a bonus
um
so yeah time at EDC is brilliant you'll
never ever say I hate my job
so during my time studying my aat level
four
um it was when the covered pandemic hit
so obviously we all had to go to working
from home and I was no longer able to go
to college to study and but working here
they gave me all of the resources I need
to be able to do that from home as well
as the support I needed and all of the
equipment I was able to continue my
studies without interruption really and
from home
um I honestly I could not recommend
working for Northeast abstra District
Council enough
um be that at an entry level like I were
when I started here
clear progression and the fact that
you're empowered to make your own
decisions and they Embrace change as
well
um the culture here is brilliant the one
team ethos that just runs through top to
bottom it's just absolutely brilliant
um I would absolutely recommend anybody
to apply for a job here
[Music]
number one
so thank you for like another thank you
Council um so any questions uh
one thing that sticks out of the
questions
[Music]
is
happening
didn't know
and I enjoyed that concept and that's
where we're going to visit
a managing whatsoever the support for
people this is because
[Music]
thank you
yeah absolutely absolutely
um
anyway
[Music]
yeah I think
yeah a couple of points
um
[Music]
for instance yeah
once outside you can go and pick the
business
of people so a great people from across
the Earth
[Music]
um
information for more reasons
yeah
um
review
and we're looking over there
and the um
the work back and you don't have to be
exactly
the most invisible
work in uh
well in terms of
the capacity yeah
[Music]
um
imposed
[Music]
is
thank you thank you
oh sorry I talked about right yeah you
talk about uh issues trying to improve
uh businesses
[Music]
potential
organizations
[Music]
money is not the problem with the name
for instance
[Music]
2005.
or less about more responsibility not
available
[Music]
YouTube
father had even if that was the parents
and particularly by example and yeah
because
we propose to do this I mean we're going
to move the benefits
of sports yeah
foreign
[Music]
um
about leadership fan of it is excellent
um two bits and I'm also my first timer
of this I'm glad it came from the
presentation
um
yeah you've got and that's what we are
in part of us it's good to know where
you want to go about that so actually
that's expensive
obviously the presentation here
[Music]
um about the council being multiple
businesses have been wrong
[Music]
foreign
really good
yeah okay
um
overall looking at it
[Music]
when we've gone down there are you doing
because
that is
um
so I think that's one where we do need
to start it's quite an important one
there's a lot of people out there though
I've never uplifted but they haven't
actually gone today success
[Music]
we've certain conditions important
I don't think the example
from the uh
on the internet
so it is
[Music]
and that's
other strengthening and finding those
links within the university so they
brought you to know that this is a place
[Music]
people
foreign
[Music]
a little bit foreign
elections
[Music]
and it's one of those opportunities
um
[Music]
foreign
um
I'm more of an engineer in The Artsy
industry and so I don't think in this
sort of way
um which is a really helpful personal
that uh problem do things like that and
in particular uh it's been really nice
to see that it's already been uh
practice forward who's been practiced
for a while
extending it so for example we've got um
the onit track when I joined and who's
developed and developed endlessly
organization and it all feeds through to
us having a reputation as well as an
employer and that's absolutely crucial
going forward so well done thank you
instructions
thank you uh yeah
[Music]
um foreign
foreign
[Music]
American Ninja
annual budget as we did on Thursday
[Music]
the Fast Tax price
Council the police Authority the Fire
Authority political Irish Council has
been taken into account as well as our
demand application
[Music]
people
all right
[Music]
thank you very much
yeah yeah
[Music]
what we realized but it was a
responsible opportunity that we get we
needed to vote for this we thought we
were down to the fact that we've got to
collected so we're yeah back on
okay
[Music]
thank you thank you what about functions
um
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
you can't sort of beer out for Council
England that's a real house Council
that's a factor that's a change
[Music]
accidents
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you chair and secondly it's the
acceptance of the report which has been
considered by the audience
and there have been an opportunity there
for all parties to have a look at this
indications
thank you thank you are there any
questions
one
okay thank you
exception
emergency
statement
reports
[Music]
energy
so I'll deal with those minor changes
first so I'm the department of paper
reading the original
uh documentaries
and the words
like that would be authors
[Music]
uh
we find that way exactly the world's
organizations
[Music]
produce
a popular place
remuneration widely
[Music]
payments amongst others
as you will see our policy includes the
introduction which states I've seen in
tender our organizational beliefs by
human culture
full of which transcription of bonus and
equality
[Music]
details on the lowest and Paris paid
employee Senior Management grading
structure
starting food roles and remuneration
positions of service
including election papers in our area
and other Financial benefits including
pension flexible retirement holidays and
discrimination
[Music]
statement
to set up clearly the difference between
the highest paid offices at the lowest
they can highlights of the difference
between the top area and the median
salary is 4.1 to 1.
and the mean salary doing 3.7
to 1. I appreciate the song that might
not mean much on your sound
there's a writing context and Incredibly
reassurance related to members into the
glass we've undertaken a comparison of
neonators in Derbyshire
very recently the wrong ratio is the
lows of all those in The Benchmark with
the most common units around five to one
between top area Turner and the median
salary with so much around six to one
the target for many local government
organizations is to achieve less than 10
times higher between top salary uh and
bottom of
6.5 to 1 stock salary means salary again
so hopefully this is along with the rest
of the post policy statement provides
summary members
that we're in a very fair and proven
chip here when it comes to play and I've
just taken a question
any questions
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
sorry
thank you
foreign
[Music]
available for people to feel like it
seem to be reimbursed to apply for it
um but obviously entertaining you've got
to balance that again
and I think it's probably there
hopefully so the general view across all
of us but we'll teach the cost of our
politics down so I would say it's a good
difficult enough
thank you
for our control counselor
yeah
foreign
[Music]
on that
level
[Music]
s that the independence
and um
[Music]
to be honest personally I'm about to
dance
that's some chicken
oh yeah thank you again um
for me whilst we're asking president to
pay more Council thanks to Geo we'll
talk about how the budgets are all being
discreetled about all the people coming
out of reserves for us to go back to
Residents
[Music]
to pay more and talk about how the
perhaps of children
finances
for the recommendations
um
foreign now
foreign
[Music]
the leadership
you're not
exercise
[Music]
thank you chair I thank you
in the mind of the public no time is
ever a good time because there's always
[Music]
and even then the public still thought
we were paid too much
[Music]
and of course this is also benchmarked
against other local Authority
and there is an disparity between one
Council and another and if you look at
enabling authorities in the amount of
allowances
in fact in some regards I think we do a
whole lot more
we do have
in real terms over a period of time in
the inflation this is being approached
to allowance for all counselors so we've
actually seen being a world in a very
over a period of time and I think it's
in the way of rectifying that
there's a recognition of what counselors
do we all know the amount of work that
we do or most of us do in our time we've
got a phone calls emails go to visit
residents all the things that nobody
knows about it's not just about things
about everything else that we do
[Music]
that's the first one
all right thank you chair
thank you yeah I've got to everybody
but I think you have to be very very
careful in my life
[Music]
in the long run
thank you
very much
[Music]
I can't agree today
foreign
[Music]
service
okay
that's right
bring me
parents will be with us
[Music]
videos
absolutely
[Music]
possibility
Council Blues cancellation that's fine
[Music]
that's a handful
that's a whole or possibility yeah
[Music]
oh
translation okay
[Music]
okay
thank you
[Music]
okay we're watching us
thank you
participation
I don't think there's anything from the
public
so we can move on to emotions
[Music]
just to confirm that we have had no
questions
we have three today's
agency we'll move to the first one
motion a the first cycle out here
[Music]
um
thankful now this can speak Chinese
[Music]
over the years the frequency of
reciprocation and state turns in in
Northeast harvested into plans because
of this decline volunteers perishing
Town Council for being forced to pay
caption themselves try to come back and
Forge of Lift us around the district
area
well that we shouldn't be there what did
the fact we do
it's our first Council to build them
some money into our projects
but we can't be expected when we fall we
need to fix authority to support more
reputation
technical results so the district
council to produce the plan on how to
improve State cleansing and properly
resources begin to start campaign
campaign to come back written throughout
Northeast Derbyshire
okay
do we have a second book
thank you
[Music]
um
look I I guess I want to start off by
saying thank you to our Philippines
[Music]
as possible uh for instance from the
last uh Team breaking that this was
today
um
being available
[Music]
different the resolution to tell you
sphere I think are a metaphary as we're
already doing both of these things and
they also miss a wider and limitation of
Left Behind dog failing and drive the
thing and so for that reason I just
can't score for today
practically anxiety thing later and our
bowing has always been a key priority
for this Administration I think many
Council they're all considered with me
certainly in our group mentioning dog
food foundation and I think the common
scene and Dutch and the doctor was so in
the world are still recovering from the
Fantastic Gun Barrel media that they did
and we are all already working on
a perceived further investing on street
team Services it's something we can do
and joy is the new director is taking a
full and fresh look at this particularly
given the roots and fractions we've had
in blender practice and Recycling and
the additional occasions that are coming
through for instance the deposit returns
being will change
correctly exactly but you will hopefully
also have an impact on on lifter in the
club but this is more than just a great
singing issue it goes over several
departments and I think we already have
a strong common Campaign which you
continue to grow to combat the third
strike is
everything
and a signage we've invested in our
environmental healthy from an important
perspective adding the equipment to
enable more enforcement and increase the
size and penalty for offenders to the
National maximum of return these changes
I think about starting the best key
results last year are important officers
carried out remote controls on record
and issued the most expenses as well as
the independency to offended to record
we do believe as part of our plumbing
campaign to remind the results
and I want to find in particular family
Rush
of their teams who were leading on a lot
of this and I disappointed and I know
it's not intended that the motion failed
to recognize
[Music]
in fact a good example for children
communities and property of care
offenders so I am grateful to all
councilors councils volunteering
residents who choose to give up their
own time to explore work at the council
and Carry Out certain things
and ideas along with many of our group
and we regularly sort of organizing
support leads and I'm grateful to speak
to how they go above and be able to
support those by learning equipment and
helping the collections
[Music]
thank you yeah yeah
level
[Music]
where
these sort of motions of actions
thank you
I just wanted to say
um as far as I've come to it I can't
query discreet so even though I think
it's about three weeks ago our recycle
happened to be on the day of the gables
where we had bins and everything
everywhere and I mean literally
everywhere there was at least three
whole bins of rubbish have been blown
across the a61 outside but inclusion
going on
um and also uh near where Mike lives the
whole Grass Valley uh
and a whole lot is clear anyway within a
couple of hours and I mean it was that
we've got wine bottles that we run over
all over the a61 by Lawrence it cleared
the lockdown there was nothing left at
all so and am I going back but I'll see
you soon
oh wow
enforced
[Music]
foreign
particularly on both flags
are having a chance with regarding
Letterman
uh
[Music]
what we do now is we look at it and we
go out
[Music]
if I'm waiting for instance
they don't do that what I would say
establish the Barker would say that they
will vote yourself
[Music]
thank you Jack completely agree with um
it's so much that you know thank you but
I hope Saturday is the wrong way
and only do you want any evidence of
that I've encourage people from my Lord
and drive from autism
on the bypass and you'll see that Andrew
I think that's the case across the whole
District always wanted to do but I think
generally on the whole we do a very good
job
and then the second point of it is the I
think issue with the idea that uh
volunteer that falls the whole point
about people
dating reacting YouTube
to take pride in communities around the
chamber on all sides will you know
actively go out and do good for picking
as part of voluntary groups and organize
and doing it I think it is important
[Music]
the maximum
my patch
[Music]
thank you
I don't care
[Music]
um
bypass
[Music]
which cuts from North international
well please
[Music]
badly disappointed thank you
thank you that's impossible
thank you
said already by uh Council and castlevan
but uh Anderson
um
[Music]
anywhere in my town
and say that yeah
but that's what I did I drove around
Longfield and we found very very little
so I can only commend our sweet scene
simple as well
thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you
oh
um
takeaways
and recognize
and
correct the word the way
and it's not balanced no
no
kind of areas that we've done yeah it's
clean but those areas
and around the earthquakes and it's
dangerous and it's dangerous to say
Joseph
was giving an area ones
[Music]
yeah
um I am going to take issues with
several members um
rather than trying to script it down
because
[Music]
foreign
since well the last eight years as I've
been involved with the Paris Council
this time increased in our village
it had something to do with the fact
that yeah we've got McDonald's
They cross is expanding driving through
recovery is the part of the car and it's
in our village it gloves about
it's factual more evidence of alien and
about it than what they did eight years
ago
needles
[Music]
I just wanted
so I'm sorry I finally what's that in
there we don't need some more resources
coming into Health
thank you chair
thank you do you have a motion before us
ing
um
listen
ing
classified
absolutely
oh that's a warehouse
[Music]
okay
once
again
[Music]
foreign
female
[Music]
this is the life of yourself
just just for classification for those
perhaps
but we never ever
in a safe environments I just wanted to
learn because we mentioned
for Children and Families
[Music]
century
you are foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
one
um I'm gonna be voting over at this
motion
um I'm incredibly concerned about this
[Music]
um
this ID situation but what my question
is it was for you guys
um
what was the campaign how are you going
to be promoting in this this isn't
something that we think that we can
change but what we can is it wouldn't be
people's awareness I go out into the
community I don't hear about this I've
been following Northeast garbages of
Facebook campaigns and
but I've gone back as far as the 14th of
December but before that that was the
first time I saw our social media
messages it was one of the 14th of
December that was on the 24th for
reporting February there was one on the
24th of February and there was one with
Billy Gardens again but you actually put
it through the link it is
but if you don't have a put for other
driving license
you have to be incredibly confirming
that it's both a r d certainly need to
get
and let's face it is a very specific
group of people
you can't afford a driving license and
passport to go on holiday and have a
platform so it's clearly aimed a
particular group of people who are going
to be discountified
but as I said my question is for you who
run the council what is your campaign
because I don't see an enormous amount
of work going on but it's about making
our community aware of it I've looked at
conservative leaflets that have been put
through my door they're not making
people aware of it so it's clearly not
your target market and that's what's
concerning them is
out there because it's not something as
high on your agenda
foreign
[Music]
doing that uh when you look at uh how
easy we can get people to our the
deadline which is 20th of April you need
to provide a protein so we've got a
national insurance number so for me I
don't think anybody should do this at
all there's one there's one part in
where this motion exception and it's
where it says there's enormous learning
on our electoral Services that's not the
case at all and I want to see what the
evidence for that is it's just something
you've made a report and it's an option
to give it more effect there's no
enormous thing it's not the case uh our
Electrical Services
at all
okay
thank you thank you
anyway
we're going to support this because as
it's only doing the marketing an essay
yeah
[Music]
and that sort of thing is
it's a word really but I don't know the
arguments is not about that but it does
this encountry and detection of the
community and we're not expecting better
I also a little bit about I think the
the things we've been sharp is it's not
so much now I could have vote if I'm on
the election day I Think We're Alone on
Election Day but people what members are
out there and each polling station as
well as a defense
some people might not like that that's
not fair
they're gonna have to police and it's
not the gay John's birthday
thank you and just
and obviously the last
but we can do that but whatever
yeah
um
[Music]
not sure if we didn't answer it but
that's because
um on what we're doing and everyone
really highlighted zero and um
normally found a new full page rather
than that
um so for me he actually has been very
limited yeah because I understand that
there's a bit of a logic for that which
is uh obviously you need to give early
narratives but people tend to go in one
way around the other this far away from
the elections however we get closer and
closer to that and then we'll be putting
much more feedback
happy that certainly finds a day with uh
who is the national campaign as well
it's quite like um
[Music]
it's it's over a year or nearly a year
now since the actual names I think the
question is
um obviously uh there's not really
significant evidence for both abroading
or Conservancy I would agree but it is a
problem in certain parts of the country
I don't think you can have
um two-tier voting in some areas
as well
um so I think I think it is important
point of principles they always provided
me that that we don't eat past or
haven't previously asked the vote your
ID or idea on 1238 it's a process that
could be very susceptible
but all the offices have in the
pollutations
uh and anyone could walk up and say that
they are Mr Smith
um
and therefore I think it's very
important and just because the policies
have been evident you know in terms of
the promotional quotes uh people find or
caution for it well that's only the
people that were called
I think it's important that we get that
it is
an initiative
um I like to turn the teams become
everyone's intensive training and lots
of preparation for it again
but I think they are well prepared and
they're doing all the right things that
they need to be the least
[Music]
and I think
thank you
um
in relation to the uh the universities
they're concerned because of 16.
but I'm sure it will clarified it so at
each polling section they have a list of
those are entitled evolved so if they
asked them
[Music]
but I think
the bit about the kids not using their
books but it's just so fast
[Music]
what's going on
yeah um
[Music]
because
they they have to turn on people they
didn't have to get them wrong for people
that are determined to unbearable
um on that day
and what what are we going to claims to
ensure that our sacritated and they've
got the fear of the library for focuses
on our head Defender
[Music]
yes
35 years
living today
um
is that we should be encouraging people
who are available
everything
is
[Music]
thank you
yeah thank you I just uh
election now but
um
[Music]
thank you
it's actually illegal to have an
application
[Music]
um
and just just in regard to the a little
bit of with the police
um obviously the weekend it falls off as
a coronation so we are expected to have
a good use of these numbers
so uh after our potentially a Hieronymus
and we would
expands there
[Music]
um
of it
[Music]
Council rights
okay
[Music]
that's a pound against that supports
okay
[Music]
you know
again
[Music]
okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
um
is
an issue that brings for the last four
years
um but when I labor performance
[Music]
to look at what
foreign
[Music]
thank you
again
uh as you know at the last meeting
because we brought back because we are
here to bring in some broader
proportionality that is
I never
wanted
to change the functions in the back just
one party having the majority I mean
everything we want to share uh to doing
that but not at the expense of allowing
[Music]
may be
uh but
this what you've heard from what we've
lost
it well whatever whoever's around the
battle around anywhere
and also
anyway I'll leave it at that we're not
supposed to be left
alcohol
thank you
[Music]
around the new system in the council's
constitution is that something that
we're able to do in a uh
[Music]
foreign
um
yeah I mean very closely weapons now
there's only eight weeks left of all the
things
[Music]
to work that out
um and uh yeah I think that's the best
way to deal with it
[Music]
thank you
yeah I think we are the same Concepts I
think we all spotted that uh yeah
whatever I think it may it may all be
there you know there's some sort of out
of this Shannon future about that uh if
we aren't going to do something like
that then
I wouldn't say if you are going to
Chairman we are going to share any power
we don't share the finance parts
thank you
um what's not going to be made
much much
[Music]
um
on this Council
now on my calculations three lenders
represent 5.6 percent
calculating
remember let's get two-thirds of them
especially responsibility allowance
and it gets them a 40 percent of the
cares
was quite as many members get to things
is
[Music]
there are a whole range of doing things
in terms of being fortunate or Fair
advice
[Music]
foreign
parking
[Music]
position parties were not responsible
and not receiving the pastors and
musicals a long time
[Music]
I totally agree and you know the
forecast
[Music]
well
that's important
thank you
bouncy but I've been saying it's so
important for the last 15 years
for those of you know a long time ago
I've always talked about this so when a
dream has come together
as well and but to say that um it's
about a cultural change that acceptable
that I wish the leader group would be
accepted
2007.
there is about giving away power and
getting power response again
[Music]
I think that we've had any responsible
approaches it to me isn't about getting
power it's about those committed that
should be delivered as a political and
student is one of those images where I
feel very strongly reaching
about it
[Music]
performance and therefore signaling that
chairs and advice proportionally
says that we found any activities
you know and I think sometimes when we
talk online
[Music]
and the one I felt very very strongly
about the million years
it's a Civic lawyer and it always
believe that a chair or a man is a
political person representing every
single member in the chamber regardless
of your politics and to politicize that
and say you know to prevent the soil
which is a phrase I heard many times
[Music]
universities
but I believe that it says and we are
very close to the election and I've been
retaining the homes
then as much as I believe that we should
be handing our chairs
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
uh
I disagree with a lot of politics
because I mean tonight
[Music]
what's that
respectable
[Music]
thank you
important
[Music]
emotions
is
very more people into that confidence
and making sure that everything is
[Music]
but in order to kind of promote that
culture we need to bring in various
voices from our own Capital
involved with generating things
through instead of this productive
[Music]
I literally was you know the software
time to improve already
[Music]
so pretty supporters knows
okay
[Music]
lots of winning
from The Wheelhouse
[Music]
okay
yes
[Music]
no it's a lot closer
has enemies
[Music]
again
yes
[Music]
um
populate
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]